it's a great privilege
University
to visit even workers and that's
reported reference from someone like me
who happens to be also someone to us
come to this interest group studies in
twenty lived with other modes of
speaking and arguing and the changes
which took place in the 1750s book books
it not only altered to so many questions
somewhat I'd read about us one of them
that they formulate the very questions
that among the question evidence from
which we companies to grasp but cabinet
Westerners broad interdisciplinary field
the philosopher has blue mark might have
said we learned through in the Diaz work
but it has we had wanted to know before
we got to know what we do know then
dimensionally two words or concepts
which play an important world in Peter
two years writings first of them
pinpoints what we discussed this
afternoon
and a syndrome and the second I assume
I'll have some very of what we're going
to
about tonight the one world concept is
experienced or should say the pair of
experience and expertise this is the
center of studies which surrounds a
certain revolution of the 17th century
and discipline experience from 1935 and
some other books experiences in only one
language as Peter dear makes clear this
cruciform what it meant in Aristotle
teacher teacher is having a sense of
what happens in our common world almost
always or almost most of the time and
what thereby Thanks I thought does not
generally our knowledge of course is
entities this experiences more we share
as rational beings expertise the
comprehension is related to individual
skills of ways how to access things
electric as parties has to do with
perception events of expertise is
created that is based on authority in
order for scientific revolution to
become possible its appearance must be
been articulated in terms of expertise
the other world
keyboarding the pita tears arrive exist
intelligibility and pierced contents
entering the title of his book
intelligibility of nature how solids
make sense of the world from 2006 the
book repeated here traverses great
historical distances from years with
darling seems to be the central figure
the intelligibility of nature refers to
an open series of devices of research
and representation of preparing things
for the investigation and theoretical
model these are all facets of the
philosophy of nature the philosophy of
nature alone that is rather resultant of
these practices and modern devices this
positive science that results from the
ways in which science is formulated
camera through and communicated this
particular show is the epitome of how
science makes sense the world or is it
possible how science makes for a
knowledge of nature that's what the
South enumerated
further books for these the chapters was
that you know certainly produce the
sciences will be announced and ambitions
1712 year again I would like you to
thank you for being here tonight
okay thank you it will be difficult for
me to represent what I'm going to talk
about today as concerning the early
modern or even the long early modern a
category that I just thought of it's
difficult to extend it as far forward as
Darwin so I'll just get on with it and
let it a so to speak speak for itself
now and the great evolutionary biologist
Ernst Meier famously claimed that the
practices of classification in natural
history underwent no sharp change
following the rapid acceptance among
naturalists in the 1860s of Darwin's
transform ISM more recently Polly
Windsor has argued for the importance of
taxonomy in the development of Darwin's
great theory at the same time rejecting
the common Association of pre-darwinian
classification with some kind of opposed
essentialism in effect her argument
similarly blends taxonomy before and
after 1859 broadly speaking these sorts
of positions I think are surely correct
Darwin especially used arguments
referring to varieties species and
generous throughout his writings and he
could hardly have expected his use of
those categories to carry any persuasive
force if it had to reinvent them
wholesale it's centrally important
though to distinguish I think between on
the one hand taxonomic ideas that were
concerned with interpretation of the
meaning of taxonomic groupings and
relationships
I mean ideas such as branching models
archetypes genealogy itself and on the
other hand taxonomic practices involving
the choice of particular characters as
classification criteria and I'm
particularly concerned with this second
question now Darwin clearly recognized
his reliance on the work of other non
Transformus taxonomy and he needed in
effect to explain how there
could have produced just such group
things as his own theory explained
through descent with modification since
these groupings served in many cases as
evidence for this theory they could
scarcely be accepted on its basis Darwin
wanted only to reinterpret their meaning
not to undermine the notion of an
already achieved natural classification
he wanted to use accepted taxa as data
for his theory when only his theory he
thought could justify them so the
question is how could that be
without argumentative circularity
clearly some other means of
acknowledging the legitimacy of the
naturalist groupings was needed and so
it appears in a well-known passage
towards the end of the Origin of Species
Darwin says the characters which
naturalist consider is showing true
affinity between any two or more species
are those which have been inherited from
a common parent and insofar all true
classification is genealogical the
community of descent is the hidden bond
which natural ists have been
unconsciously seeking so like Arthur
Koestler sleepwalkers Darwin's fellow
naturalists those unenlightened by the
doctrine of descent with modification
were on the right track without knowing
it and they'd often used correct
procedures in going about their work of
classification without knowing what
justified those procedures and Darwin
can now tell them what they've been
doing all along speaking the prose of
transform ISM and I should stress at
this point that of course I'm not myself
aligning myself with cursors notion of
sleepwalking scientists stumbling
towards the truth now that Darwin had
faith in the practices of conventional
taxonomy
appears throughout his work in Chapter
two of the Origin he'd drawn attention
to the difficulties that were attendant
on discriminating between distinct
species and mere varieties rather than
denying the reality of that distinction
though
he explains how it should be managed in
practice so this is Darwin again hence
in determining whether a form should be
ranked as a species or a variety the
opinion of naturalists having sound
judgment and wide experience seems the
only guide to follow
we must however in many cases decide by
a majority of natural ists for few well
marked and well-known varieties can be
named which have not been ranked to
species by at least some competent
judges now know that there's no question
here of not deciding the question
distinguishing between varieties and
species is what natural ists do and
Darwin had no interest in rocking the
boat this isn't to say that Darwin
trusted the community of naturalist
always to get things right this was
particularly problematic in the
discrimination between varieties and
species the criteria used were generally
morphological and not dependent on
evidence of membership in a common
reproductive community Darwin knew that
that wasn't any clear-cut criterion
anyway naturalist Darwin assumed
reproduced the natural order in their
responses to it he Illustrated the
problem by imagining a beginner in the
process of joining the coterie of
natural ists
having the requisite sound judgment and
wide experience that's the pre-existing
expert naturalist so he says when a
young naturalist commences the study of
a group of organisms quite unknown to
him he is at first much perplexed to
determine what differences to consider
as specific and what as varieties for he
knows nothing of the amount and kind of
variation to which the group is subject
and this shows at least have very
generally there is some variation so the
ubiquity of variation is affirmed not by
its existence in nature but by the
inexperienced naturalist supposed
perplexity and then Darwin goes on but
if he can find his attention to one
class within one country he will soon
make up his mind how to rank most of the
doubtful
forms his general tendency will be to
make many species for he will become
impressed
just like the pigeon or poultry fancier
with the amount of difference in the
forms which he is continually studying
and he has little general knowledge of
analogical variation in other groups and
in other countries by which to correct
his first impressions the culmination of
this type of the young naturalist
acquiring taxonomic competence once he
extends his knowledge appropriately is
that he will in the end generally be
enabled to make up his own mind which to
call varieties and which species but he
will succeed in this at the expense of
admitting much variation he will have
become in other words one of those who
have sound judgment and wide experience
now Darwin's deference to expert
judgment in these sorts of cases wrested
of course on his conviction well before
he wrote the origin that varieties
species genera as well as all the higher
taxonomic groupings bore similar
relations to one another general being
two species as species were two
varieties or subspecies and with no
essential distinction between them he
says I look at the term species as one
arbitrarily given for the sake of
convenience to a set of individuals
closely resembling each other and that
it does not essentially differ from the
term variety nonetheless the judgment of
expert naturalist saan these sorts of
questions weren't therefore meaningless
for Darwin they contained truths
revealing of the natural world itself
this was despite the inevitable
disagreements between those experts
Darwin's assent assertion that the
budding naturalist will eventually be
able to judge what to call varieties and
what species only by as he said
admitting much variation is wryly
qualified with the remark that the truth
of this admission will often be disputed
by other naturalists now Darwin's use of
the classification conclusions of his
fellow naturalists typically took the
form of using those conclusions as
surrogate phenom
it should be borne in mind of course
that determinations of the reality of
taxonomic groupings differed from
descriptive accounts of particular
organisms Darwin very frequently cited
descriptions of organisms behaviors or
attributes based on accounts provided to
him by correspondence or in published
authoritative those people of the kind
employed in reckoning some form a
distinct species or a new variety of a
known species were something else again
Darwin turn such judgments to account in
a variety of ways one is displayed
shortly after the foregoing discussion
from Chapter two of the origin from
looking at species as only strongly
marked and well-defined varieties I was
led to anticipate that the species of
the larger general in each country would
often our present varieties than the
species of the smaller General in his
evidential evidentiary material for
testing this anticipation was the
systematic work of other natural ists as
he'd already explained he says I thought
that some interesting results might be
obtained in regard to the nature and
relations of the species which vary most
by tabulating all the varieties in
several well worked Flora's now despite
acknowledging the difficulties which
have been urged on him especially by
Joseph Hooker that would have to attend
this sort of procedure Darwin went ahead
with his comparisons anyway expert
Authority again underpinned his
arguments which were prefaced by the
imprimatur of Hooker himself who Darwin
says thinks that the following
statements are fairly well established
now the origin doesn't itself contain
any of the tables that Darwin drew up to
record the relevant numbers some appear
in the manuscript texts of his big
species book that the origin supplanted
the data of the guileless naturalist
gathered without any theoretical axes to
grind serve Darwin as an apparently
neutral test of his suppositions this is
despite the fact that Darwin recognizes
no sharp discrimination
between varieties and species allows
considerable variation among individuals
and is therefore accordingly unsurprised
by disagreement among naturalists
on particular instances his numbers in
other words seem to refer to entities
conjured up by the naturalist yet for
these purposes Darwin treats them as if
they were mere descriptions of nature
judgments of significant similarities
and differences cannot by their nature
be descriptive of course they are
fundamentally evaluative but evaluative
of what now Darwin's remark in the
origin to the effect that the characters
which naturalist consider is showing
true affinity between any two or more
species are those which have been
inherited from a common parent that
gives no clue as to what those natural
ists themselves thought they were doing
it merely tells us what Darwin believed
they were really doing naturalist some
reasons for their choices of
classification criteria were from that
perspective strictly irrelevant because
those reasons were not correctly based
on notions of common descent instead the
only point of interest for Darwin was
the final classification range mminton
cluded by the naturalist the fundamental
grounds on which it was explicitly
justified couldn't be held relevant to
its assessment the skilled naturalist
decisions were for Darwin data to be
used as evidence they couldn't by their
very nature be reasons or arguments and
when Darwin referred to systematic
classification of organisms he
necessarily invoked a considerable
history of taxonomic theory and practice
the theory made sense of what Darwin
often described as affinities in nature
but the determination of true affinities
needed for his project to be
accomplished independently of a
specification of what those affinities
really meant the holy grail of the
naturalist classifier had long been and
in the 18th century had become codified
as the natural system now that kind of
taxonomic system would transcend the me
conventional as Darwin put it puts it
like the grouping of the stars in
constellations and it would transcend
the conventional by representing the
true affinities of the different beings
found in nature the result will be the
long-sought natural system Carl Linnaeus
had spent his life in search of this
system all the while doubting that he'd
succeeded in approaching it his own
Linnaeus has only laborat with their
selections of characters designed to
assist the naturalist in pigeonholing
new species
he himself characterized as artificial
by the turn of the century you have
various natural ists most notably on
Tuan lure and Azusa and georges cuvier
making claims to the invention of a set
of criteria that would yield a
justifiably natural classification in
both botany and zoology the asserted
naturalness in each case derived from
functional associations of the selected
classification characters which provided
arguments for an appropriate
subordination of function to function
and thereby character to character in a
hierarchy that could be mapped onto the
hierarchy of taxonomic categories that
typifies Linnaeus's widely used or
imitated practical systems the
proposition that taxonomic practice
yielded a natural system of
classification was therefore largely
accepted in the first half of the 19th
century even though the theoretical
arguments for its validity were
sometimes rather sketchy Darwin in
effect accepted it too but his grants
for doing so took on a paradoxical cast
as he became committed to descent with
modification as the true cause of the
affinities proclaimed by the
classification developed by other
naturalist by the time of the origin the
especially influential work of Cuvier
with its subordination of characters
rule to guide functional zoological
texts on it taxonomy had lost
theoretical and practical grand to
purely morphological aspects of
comparative anatomy yet the
non-conventional natural image of
classification still had survived
Darwyn therefore represented the
underlying sentiment supporting the
standard view of the natural system of
classification as an idealistic
conception of the kind that predated the
functional approaches of the late
eighteenth century this is what he says
some authors look at the natural system
merely as a scheme for arranging
together those living objects which are
most alike and for separating those
which are most unlike or as an
artificial means for annunciate as
briefly as possible general propositions
but many natural ists think that
something more is meant by the natural
system they believe that it reveals the
plan of the Creator but unless it be
specified whether order in time or space
or what else is meant by the plan of the
creator it seems to me that nothing is
the added to our knowledge so Darwin
fully accepted the naturalness of the
natural system but not in the same way
as that in which most other natural ists
did whether based on function the
adequacy of which Darwin promptly
impugns or in divinity now in order to
establish the meaning and ontological
foundation of the natural systems
supposed naturalness Darwin has first
therefore to accept that naturalness as
a given and only then to infer its true
sense classification was supposed to
reveal affinities between organisms but
like the plan of the creator unspecified
kinds of affinity might seem to add
little to our knowledge
here's Darwin again such expressions as
that famous one of Linnaeus in which we
often meet within a more or less
concealed form that the characters do
not make the genus but that the genus
gives the characters seem to imply that
something more is included in our
classification than mere resemblance now
that almost Vic and Stein Ian's view
places the taxonomic cart before the
clasificado a horse conviction of the
existence of the genus precedes
knowledge of the characters that serve
to I
identify it just as the entire taxonomic
system proceeds for Darwin the
classification criteria that justify it
his genealogical explanation of existing
natural taxonomy x' makes sense
Darwin reckoned of the very
classification procedures that produce
them so he says on this idea of the
natural system being in so far as it's
being perfected genealogical in its
arrangement we can understand the rules
which we are compelled to follow in our
classification we can understand why we
value certain resemblances far more than
others why we are permitted to use
rudimentary and useless organs or others
of trifling physiological importance now
a crucial feature of this assertion is
that it represents classification
procedures as ones carried out not
according to merely general rules but to
rules that we are as Darwin says
compelled to follow Darwin asserts this
idea that the naturalist is willy-nilly
compelled to proceed in particular ways
without explaining the nature of the
compulsion the only evidence for its
existence is the supposition that
natural ists do in fact follow such
procedures and that natural ists are not
for the most part capricious in doing so
as Darwin puts it elsewhere in the
origin descent was the hidden bond of
connection which natural ists have been
seeking under the term of the natural
system evidently all unbeknownst to
themselves
Darwin offers only a strictly irrelevant
ontological argument for the origin of
the accepted classification compulsions
explaining that his genealogical account
of their suitability enables us as he
says to understand them but that
argument still fails to explain why
naturalists who do not recognize that
what they're doing is in fact we
constructing genealogies nonetheless in
fact do so as a counterpoint Darwin sets
up as the only alternative account of
the natural system this rather antique
view of it as revealing the plan of the
creator which he seems to treat as a
rather weak straw man position the
mystery of how without The Naturalist
having prior knowledge of it the
creator's plan could serve to direct the
naturalist specificity compulsions is in
fact no more obscure than than the
mystery of how a conjectured
genealogical origin of classification
knowledge could reveal itself through
the naturalist sleepwalking practices
the natural system accepted in advance
begs the question of its own discovery
perhaps though the compulsions didn't
flow from the classification rules
themselves let alone going behind the
rules from their justifying ontology
whether it's the natural system as God's
plan or as the outcome of descent with
modification perhaps Darwin meant
instead the sort of primitive behaviors
that made human beings favor
ornamentation of the body or peahens
admire the gaudy plumage of peacocks
taxonomy in other words perhaps worked
rather like sexual selection discussed
at such great length in Darwin's descent
of man in 1871 why females of some
species preferred particular supposedly
beautiful features in the male's Darwin
never really explained except by
reference to some shared aesthetic
sensibility it's hard not to suspect a
vicious circularity in his arguments
insofar as in those sorts of cases
Darwin can suggest no functional
advantage for those preferences in a
similar way the naturalist compulsion in
his selections of classification
criteria were also primitive and
inexplicable yet somehow resulted
through some great pre-established
harmony in a taxonomic system that
correspond it to the true natural system
of descent with modification now in
practice this is certainly how Darwin
tended to establish the legitimacy of
taxonomic judgments he routinely cited
what one might expect naturalists to do
in some case of classification
determination
although there's a subtle
differentiation between is generic
indications of classification practice
and those of named and presumably
especially competent naturalist
as to the former cases the generic cases
generic natural ists may often be
deceived according to Darwin
thus Darwin on on show pigeons he says
altogether at least a score of pigeons
might be chosen which if shown to an
ornithologist and he were told that they
were wild birds would certainly I think
be ranked by him as well-defined species
or this other quote on the issue of what
we now call convergent evolution he says
a naturalist struck by a parallelism of
this nature in any one class by
arbitrarily raising or sinking the value
of the groups in other classes and all
our experience shows that this valuation
as hitherto be an arbitrary could easily
extend the parallelism over a wide range
and thus the Septon or equine Ariki
ternary and ternary classifications have
probably arisen and then by contrast we
have approving citations of apparently
dispositive judgments as with this
reference to the Oxford ornithologist
John Gould mr. Gould remarked to me long
ago that in those general of birds which
range over the world many of the species
have very wide ranges I can hardly doubt
that this rule is generally true though
it will be difficult to prove it now
Darwin's acceptance of goulds
generalization seems to rest largely on
a reliance on gold's abilities to see
the realities behind formal criteria
because otherwise as Darwin says it will
be difficult to prove it
Gould was of course the gaunt ethology
Sioux persuaded Darwin that the finches
he collected in the Galapagos should be
classed as distinct species and not as
Darwin had previously supposed merely
different varieties darwin's earlier
acceptance of that judgment is really
rather worth noting because it indicates
not only that Darwin in this case became
increasingly aware of the fine line
between varieties and species as he
reported but also that the taxon
judgment itself retains some
significance for him he could have
decided that Gold's determination
clouded the distinctness of these
categories and then merely have taken
them less seriously in the future but he
chose instead to retain the socially
entrenched taxonomic category of species
and to use the delicacy of judgment that
it involved as evidence of the way that
distinct species can be seen as emerging
gradually from previous merely varietal
distinctions
now another instance of the Jessup
knowledge or wisdom that Darwin takes to
lie behind the best classification
practices appears in the origins chapter
devoted to classification this is what
he notes there at one point when a speck
Harper produced in France during several
years only degraded flowers departing so
wonderfully in a number of the most
important points of structure from the
proper type of the order yet Monsieur
Shire sagaciously saw as Yasuo observes
that this genus should still be retained
amongst the malp Iggy a seeing this case
seems to me well to illustrate the
spirit with which our classifications
are sometimes necessarily founded so
l'esprit systematic here comes to the
aid of the botanist who might otherwise
be misled by his materials and this
privilege ring of the favored expert
naturalist over his work ad a nameless
colleagues he is by no means uniform in
the way Darwin talks about these matters
the chapter on classification in the
origin also cites as further support the
tendency of taxonomist
to disregard the physiological
importance of the characters that they
privilege when making classification
assignments so he says practically when
natural ists are at work they do not
trouble themselves about the
physiological value of the characters
which they use in defining a group or in
allocating any particular species if
they find a character nearly uniform and
common to a great number of forms and
not common to others they use it as one
of high value if common to some lesser
number they use it as
subordinate value now support for the
rightness of this taxonomic behavior is
then found by Darwin in the judgments of
the most August authorities he says this
principle has been broadly confessed by
some natural ists to be the true one and
by none more clearly than by that
excellent botanist bogus Santilli if
certain characters are always fan
correlated with others though no
apparent bond of connection can be
discovered between them as special value
is set on them so according to Darwin
this is what even the best of naturalist
generally do and Darwin clearly affords
it considerable evidential value as to
how it ought to be done one final
example evidently referring here without
naming him to the great zoologist
Richard Owen among others Darwin writes
towards the end of the origin naturalist
frequently speak of the skull as formed
of metamorphose vertebrae the jaws of
crabs has metamorphosed legs the stamens
and pistils of flowers as metamorphosed
leaves naturalist so ever use such
language only in a metaphorical sense on
my view these terms may be used
literally so yet again natural ists were
on the right track but had no suspicion
of that tracks true import now Darwin's
overt classification practice wasn't
restricted to his drawing on the
judgments of other natural ists only
when making broad comparative arguments
his own detailed work on classification
shows similar and necessary reliance on
the sensibilities one might almost say
moral authority of other natural ists
his principal taxonomic endeavor the
great work on the class Sura pedia
published in the early 1850s in the case
of living barnacles contains much
detailed anatomical description for
which Darwin actually apologizes he says
although the present volume is strictly
systematic I will under the general
description of a leopard any day
difficult to announce that leopard is a
day give a very brief
tract of some of the most interesting
points in their internal anatomy and in
the meta morphosis of the whole class
which I hope hereafter to treat with the
necessary illustrations in detail darwin
was particularly interested in all this
work as he told his friend hooker in the
light that curious variations in sexual
dimorphism and hermaphroditism through
on the evolutionary origins of sex but
of course those kinds of arguments
couldn't ever appear explicitly in this
pre origin apparently technical
systematic work the more
straightforwardly classification work
appears more clearly in darwin's
companion volumes on fossil sera peds
where internal anatomy wasn't a
consideration nonetheless the earlier
work on living barnacles was essential
to the work especially given the limited
number of specimens and the usual large
variability of many features that were
exhibited by individual species of
barnacle darwin as before was of course
especially concerned with naming and he
adhered scrupulously to the instituted
standards proclaimed by the British
Association in 1842 which had made the
1758 10th edition of Linnaeus's Systema
naturae the starting point for naming
practices and the precedence for
priorities in naming and I might mention
that Darwin was himself a member of the
relevant committee of the British
Association Darwin was careful
throughout this work to locate himself
inside this ongoing communal enterprise
and he simply found it unnecessary to
use evolutionary arguments to justify
his focus on for example homologies as
being a particular classification
significance because after all there
were always other natural ists to be
cited who had behaved similarly even if
their justifications weren't
transferable to his work in practice
classification was always very much a
communal endeavor and the work of other
naturalist was as much of a foundation
as were morphological characters
themselves in all these examples the
alleged behavior of natural ists
is used to reveal something
about nature itself whether they
realized it or not in classifying plants
and animals natural ists
were mapping at genealogical
relationships among organisms
relationships that could only properly
be understood with the assistance of
Darwin's theory so why does Darwin trust
them how does he think that they're
capable of doing this the question I
think requires a bit of consideration of
Darwin's implicit anthropology master
say of his understanding of human beings
and their relationship to the natural
world as a whole
Darwin always resisted the elevation of
man to a state qualitatively superior to
the rest of nature his treatment of
human origins have from the start been
thoroughly naturalistic with the most
characteristic human traits namely those
of intellect and aesthetic judgment for
Darwin being routinely compared as
matters of degree with they're supposed
equivalents in other animals one of his
means of doing this involved discussing
the anatomy of the brain taking the
brain as the organ of the mind
Darwin liked to emphasize the basic
comparability of the human brain and
those of other primates in the descent
of man of course he confronts his old
adversary Richard Owen on precisely this
point he notes that Owen quote relying
chiefly on the structure of the brain
divided mammals into four subclasses one
of which contained man alone now
Darwin's technique for dismissing the
plausibility of Owens classification was
quite simple he says this view has not
been accepted as far as I am aware by
any naturalist capable of forming an
independent judgment and therefore need
not here be further considered now the
lack of substantive argument isn't
simply a matter of scorn for Owen it
reflects the nature of classification
itself the enumeration of specific
criteria would only provide grounds for
controversy so that nothing but the
judgment of competent natural ists
could ever settle that kind of question
definitively
Darwin's use of the community's
taxonomic judgments comes into play
especially in his discussion of human
races the theme which is discussed at
length in descent of man relies heavily
once again on taxonomic arguments that
are rooted in the classification
behavior actual or presumed of
contemporary natural ists after a lot of
consideration about what a
representative naturalist might be
expected to do about the question Darwin
concludes that taking into account
various standard sorts of arguments for
separating the races of man into
separate species or else linking them
together as one great species with BAPS
various geographically distinct
varieties he cuts the Gordian knot by in
effect dismissing the whole question as
insoluble insofar as the term species
itself is essentially vague he says if
we reflect on the weighty arguments for
raising the races of man to the dignity
of species and the insuperable
difficulties on the other side in
defining them the term subspecies might
here be used with much propriety but
then he admits habit will probably leave
the term race as the one that people
will continue to use and so does Darwin
himself in his subsequent discussions in
descent of man what's of most concern to
Darwin is to argue for a mono genetic
origin for all humanity as against the
polygen Asteria multiple origins four
distinct races how its use of divergence
among different lines of human descent
might be handled taxonomically is then
of less moment to him james moore and
adrian desmond have quite recently
argued that the involvement of Darwin
and his family including his grandfather
Erasmus Darwin in the abolitionist cause
gave Darwin's position particular
salience but there can be no doubt of
the the wholly naturalistic way in which
Darwin subsumes the classification of
human beings to precisely the same
procedures and taxonomic issues as
applied to the rest of the organic world
the analogy is total the similarities
between the classification of animals
and that of human beings still involve
centrally for Darwin the you
of the naturalist or most natural ists
as the crucial credential for taxonomic
judgment so for example he matches the
ambiguities attending the classification
of South American seevis monkeys with
similar approaches to human types
he says if numerous specimens of Seba
sworkit of from all parts of south
america and those forms which are
present appear to be specifically
distinct were found to graduate into
each other by closed steps they would be
ranked by most natural ists as mere
varieties or races and thus the greater
number of natural ists have acted with
respect to the races of man hence the
fundamental ambiguities surrounding the
issue which were all applicable in
Darwin's view to the case of humanity if
on the other hand the races of man were
the result of convergent evolution from
two quite distinct forebears as in an
analogous case of certain pigs Darwin
says it can hardly be doubted that
marked differences in the structure of
certain bones would still have been
discoverable in man as he now exists now
what's of particular importance to
Darwin is that no characteristic feature
of modern man should set him apart from
other animals that nothing qualitatively
unique be found in man and man alone so
he makes a special point of making the
case that what he calls human
intellectual powers are themselves
nothing but the highest level of a
continuous distribution
he says the development of these powers
in animals does not offer any special
difficulty for with our domesticated
animals the mental faculties are
certainly variable and the variations
are inherited therefore the conditions
are favorable for their development
through natural selection or as he puts
it more colorfully elsewhere he says the
mental faculties of man and the lower
animals do not differ in kind
although immensely in degree a
difference in degree however great does
not justify a sim placing man in a
distinct Kingdom as will perhaps be best
illustrated by comparing the mental
powers of two insects namely a caucus or
scale in
sect and an ant which undoubtedly
belonged to the same class and he then
gives an account of the remarkable
behaviors of ants as contrasted with the
doll and inactive caucus the so called
moral sense receives a similar general
treatment he says the first foundation
or origin of the moral sense lies in the
social instincts including sympathy and
these instincts no doubt were primarily
gained as in the case of the lower
animals through natural selection now
the image here of nature knowing itself
is inescapable it seems to me but in a
rather direct way and one that goes
beyond attributing special powers to
human beings themselves simply taken as
part of nature Darwin wanted mental
abilities to be a seen as a part of
nature produced through natural
selection like most things in the
organic world and only differences in
degree not differences in kind were
involved it follows from this that human
taxonomic abilities which sleepwalker
naturalists display were not themselves
unique in the animal kingdom and so
Darwin effectively acknowledged when in
1863 he addressed the entomologist Henry
Bates work on protective mimicry mimicry
in Amazonian butterflies one species of
butterfly toothsome two predatory birds
had markings very similar to another
much more populous species that was
noxious to those same birds the
historian Stefan Muller villa has noted
darwin's remark in his review of bates
first paper on this subject that the
similarity was so great that mr. Bates
says Darwin with his eyes sharpened by
collecting during 11 years was though
always on my guard
thus Bates continually deceived Bates in
other words on Darwin's view clearly
possessed taxonomic intuitions much like
those of Amazonian birds even when they
were misled now this commonality of
human classification compulsions
those animals shows why Darwin was so
comfortable with seconding the aesthetic
preferences of peahens anthropomorphism
of this kind was neither naive nor
capricious instead certain things were
simply what animals including humans
found beautiful but how could that kind
of unity justify taxonomic judgments of
similarity or difference how could it
give force to the compulsions of the
naturalist Darwin in effect naturalized
the so called natural system in the end
whatever naturalist tended to do was in
the main determined by the mysterious
compulsions trained by natural selection
but in practice this meant that Darwin
was happy to rest some confidence in the
general classification tendencies
expressed by people who were in fact
appropriately socialized members of the
European Natural History community the
natural system might not have reflected
God's plan in Darwin's view but it did
reflect in a durkheimian sort of way
perhaps the judgments of his own
scientific colleagues those colleagues
were Darwin's mirror of nature ok thank
you